on est face à un sénat qui ne ressemble
pas tellement à la photographie
politique aujourd'hui qui est bouleversé
on le voit on l'a vu à l'occasion de la
présidentielle et des législatives est
par ailleurs moi je pense que il
souhaite être garant de cette
institution qu'est le sénat et nous nous
voulons une nouvelle république
la 6ème république suivante et que de ce
point de vue le sénat ne nous paraît pas
être l'institution je vous faites du
sénat dans la 6ème république
je me suis pris mais oui je pense qu'il
faut deux chambres mais c'est fâcheux
oubli camériste si deux chambres c'est
possible a bien sûr mais les deux
chambres peuvent être avec nous même
rôle avec le même nom avec des allers
retours je suis pas forcément opposé au
fait qu'ils aient deux chambres mais ça
mériterait de longs débats mais en tout
cas je ne ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui le
sénat dans la façon dont il est désigné
soit un atout pour le dynamisme
démocratique de notre pays je le crois
pas gérard larcher on a fait si vous
voulez la chambre qui défendent les
territoires effet peut constituer un
petit peu comme cela vous êtes à quand
vous faites un peu l'amour pourquoi ben
un député qui est élu d'un territoire
défend ici son territoire comme le sinaï
alors par contre ce qui m'inquiète c'est
quand je vois le projet du gouvernement
qui veut faire en sorte que les
circonscriptions des législatives soit
en gros le double de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui ça va pas aider à rapprocher
les citoyens de leurs élus et à défendre
correctement des territoires à
l'assemblée nationale justement vous
avez vous craignez ce qu'on appelle le
redécoupage de la carte électorale pour
ceux qui connaissent vraiment mais on va
re découper un peu les circonscriptions
ça c'est une le projet 40 est emmanuel
macron est un projet hyper
technocratique qui vise tout simplement
à la mine et le rôle des parlementaires
d'ailleurs je trouve qu'un petit parfum
antiparlementaire qui se dégage dans ce
pays et en particulier de la part de
cette majorité gouvernementale
et oui je le conteste pas ce que je
pense qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie sans
représentant du peuple aujourd'hui